Queen one of my favorite rock bands of
all time
not like the biggest rock and roll
fanatic but you know one of my favorite
rock bands ever Queen
has just dropped one of its biggest hits
from its greatest hits collection the
new greatest hits collection for Queen
will not include Fat Bottom Girls oh
you're gonna take me home tonight oh
down beside that red fire light oh won't
you let it all hang out Fat Bottom Girls
you make the rock and roll go around
that's gonna be out this song was
written in 1978 it's been a big hit ever
since was written by Brian May who's a
big lib
worth pointing that out because I think
this is crucial here and it would appear
though the band hasn't made any
statement on it that the libs of Queen
and the record label have caved to the
woke people who have said that this song
is Politically Incorrect and that it's
mean to fat women or something like that
and you might be saying Michael that
explanation doesn't make any sense
because we live in the world of lizzo we
live in the world of body positivity
Fat Bottom Girls should be an Anthem
except Fat Bottom Girls is kind of a
cheeky funny song it's kind of making a
little bit of a joke about it
kind of like uh what's that song Lola
Lola you know who's a a dude but looks
like a chick or whatever you don't
really hear that song as much anymore
because it's kind of it's a song about
a certain
psychosexual phenomenon that we're not
allowed to talk about on YouTube but
you'd think well maybe you'd hear that
song more now as that uh ideological fad
has become more prevalent but no because
it's kind of making fun of it well here
Fat Bottom Girls is kind of making fun
of it but it shouldn't but shouldn't
that be positive too can't we
appropriate that term just like LGBT
activists have reappropriated queer it
doesn't hold on what's going on I'll
tell you exactly what's going on it's
the catch-22
of woke culture
you see this if you're a white guy you
see this if you if you serve tacos at
your dinner party
if you serve tacos at your dinner party
as a white person that is cultural
appropriation
if you don't serve tacos at your dinner
party as a white person that's cultural
Erasure
if you wear a sombrero and Cinco de Mayo
cultural appropriation if you don't
acknowledge Cinco de Mayo cultural
Erasure
those are two Mexican examples but they
go throughout the entire culture and so
here if you have a fun song about
slightly more corpulent Buxom women
uh
that would be
appropriation I guess that would be or
making light of this issue or making fun
or being derisive but if you don't it's
Erasure what do you do what do you do
you shut up that's what you do the
reason the reason the queen has to get
rid of this song is not because of this
the subject matter of the song The
Reason Queen has to get rid of the song
is because they're white guys
the nearest thing to a not white guy in
Queen was Freddie Mercury and he's been
dead for decades so they can't do it
it's not that this sort of thing cannot
be talked about it's that you can't talk
about it right now text Knowles to 98 98
98 as central banks in countries like
China India and Australia begin
transitioning to a digital currency the
Federal Reserve has been contemplating
the same for the U.S with a digital
currency the government could track
every single purchase you make officials
could even prohibit you from purchasing
certain products or easily freeze or
seize part or all of your money these
are some of the reasons concerned
Americans reach out to Birch gold they
want to have a physical asset like gold
that is independent of the US dollar you
can protect your IRA or 401K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now learn if gold is right for you
too text Knowles Canada WLS to 98 98 98
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
upon again text Knowles Canada wlas to
98.98 98. right now go to medishare.com
Michael as a daily wire listener you are
not just informed you're handsome also
engaged and you value personal
responsibility Freedom or way of life
that is why we think that you will like
Medi share Medishare is a community
based approach to healthcare that lines
up with the principles that you believe
in your values matter with Medishare
your health care dollars won't be used
for medical procedures that don't line
up with your beliefs metashare is the
highest rated Healthcare sharing
Ministry with a 30-year proven track
record it's not health insurance it's a
community of 400 000 Believers committed
to caring and sharing for one another
members save up to fifty five zero
percent or more on their monthly health
care costs for limited time daily wire
listeners will get a 100 150 dollar gift
card when you join Medishare to find out
more go to metashare.com Michael that is
medishare.com
Medi share.com slash Michael terms and
conditions apply
now getting back to money Joe Biden
has just brought some great news out
this is I had missed this achievement of
his administration Joe Biden
has for the first time in many many
decades
decreased the national debt allegedly
and unlike the last president in my
first two years in office even with all
we've done
I'm the first one to cut the federal
debt by one trillion 700 billion dollars
one trillion 700 billion dollars cut one
trillion 700 billion dollars cut from
the debt since Biden took office except
actually since Biden took office the
debt has increased 4.175 trillion
dollars
so that's a Delta
of
five or six trillion dollars that's hmm
how do you reconcile those two things oh
Biden's just lying Biden has not cut the
debt at all he's massively increased it
according to
Moody's now what about the deficit so
maybe maybe Biden meant to say he's cut
the deficit rather than the debt right
the debt is just the total amount of
money that we owe the deficit
is how much more money we're spending
every year than the money that we're
taking in well according to Moody's
uh Biden's actions in his first two
years quote have undoubtedly resulted in
higher deficits not smaller ones
so Biden has increased the debt
massively he's increased the debt
massively by maintaining or according to
Moody's Analytics increasing the deficit
so what he said just isn't true it's
completely divorced from reality I I
couldn't even begin to tell you what he
was trying to say
so he's either a liar which he is
or he inadvertently got this wrong out
of incompetence he's also incompetent so
I don't know which of the two it is
either way though you might be saying
well how is this guy going to get
reelected he's running for office again
on not a lot of accomplishments and we
were talking about the importance of
personality when you're when you're
running for office well how's he going
to get elected if he seems incapacitated
because what other option do the
Democrats have
what other option do they have
he unless he actually dies in office or
on the campaign Trail this guy is going
to be the nominee he wants it he doesn't
like Kamala Harris he doesn't like
people to judge for goodness sakes he
doesn't like Gavin Newsom this guy has
spent every waking moment since he was
two years old maybe since he was in the
womb figuring out how to be president
that's all he wants in life
he's not going to just give it up unless
he's dragged out of there by his ankles
so he's going to be the nominee and if
he's the nominee and you're a Democrat
what are you going to do you're going to
vote for Trump probably not you probably
have a better shot at voting for Trump
than you do of voting for a standard GOP
type A Mitt Romney or a John McCain
because at least Trump is weird and
populist and upends GOP Orthodoxy on a
handful of policies at least but still
you're probably just going to vote for
bye you're gonna vote for Cornell West
you're gonna no you're probably just
gonna vote for Biden so
even even if he gets everything wrong
that he says even if his
presidency is unsuccessful
if you were a Democrat why wouldn't you
vote for him you're going to vote for
orange Hitler the mango Mussolini that
the media have just spent seven years
telling you is the greatest threat ever
in the history of our country
even if DeSantis is the nominee you're
gonna vote for DeSantis
Ron death santis the killer of Ponte
Vedra who who slaughtered senior
citizens during covid according to the
liberal media no who are you gonna vote
for
the vague they'll figure out something
about the vague if somehow he's the
nominee
no you're gonna vote for Biden even if
it's Weekend at Bernie's in the Stream
up like a marionette what a great clip
that was huh wasn't that good well if
you want more of it you got to subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time